And I myself
I teach us on and now people start doing
like a business. There are some out
there doing for Allah even they get
money it's not going to get money but
some people are doing it for the sake of
doing it. Okay. So what I would say to
you look to to the to the prophecy in
the Quran which Allah mentioned to these
prophets you will never be killed or
you'll die and they didn't convey the
message. Many people tried to kill him
and they were not successful and he
conveyed his message when he died in his
house and he
said so I'm
sure why the truth it's impossible to
come from prophecies and
miracles just like science is coming
Jesus is coming
it can't be okay it can't be because a
man Jesus like I'm
not but I'm saying use our intellect the
manmade okay had enemies why they didn't
do what he did
you know there were many people the
prophet Muhammad claimed to be
prophet but none of them all of them
were exposed were only him even though
they were his enemies
even his enemy some Islam accepted
something accept And they were looking
for anything to do to validate
prophethood to to to let him and they
were successful. Who Allah gave victory
to who? To the prophet
Muhammad. Jesus is God. Jesus is God.
Jesus
is Jesus
is overwhelming. Alhamdulillah.
Yes. Muslim have to
do people like this to see what ISIS
and why you die for the
truth. For the the truth.
Of course, for the sake of Allah. will
die for sake of Allah. You're dying to
save humanity
to make sure this truth that you're
dying for Allah for the humanity to
follow it and to not follow
Satan. So if the humanity understood
what you're dying for, you appreciate
your death cuz you know there's many
people out there evil right there.
There's many evil people out there who
they want to die for Satan. Jesus is
God. Did that for Satan by trying to
stop? Of course, God's mouth. But we
still Yeah. That's why God take their
lives.
Jesus. That's the contus.
Of course. Because whatever proposed
Islamic teaching is false.
No. Judaism and Christianity. We believe
there's some truth in it. Yes. We
believe there's some truth. We know some
practices
in
Moses practice circumcision. Jesus
pract Islam makes sense. Islam when you
look at Islam that's why Islam is
spreading in the west where there is
many propaganda against Islam. Yet still
English woman and English man and French
and Scottish and Irish accepted Islam.
Who do you think uh is creating the
propaganda against? I believe evil big
country Freemasons and there's evil
society out there. Satanic people. Of
course, any doubt because satanic people
cuz you know when you look back to the
history when Allah created Adam and and
Eve who is our first enemy it was andl
he wanted to take people away from God's
worship. Why? because he has grudge and
and hate against the sons of Adam
because he believe we deceived him.
Okay. That's why subhan Allah we have to
understand. Have you been Algeria?
If you want to go to Algeria, what would
you do first? You decide the country
which currency they use the language.
Yes. Likewise, one day you're going to
die. All of us here are going to die. No
one is going to be saved from the death.
The queen, she had the best doctors.
But yes, you die. Allah is not able to
travel. Dying is a type of traveling. So
we should learn
You don't exist. How
you
understand
somewhere before that's why they create
a source before the body. What's that
called? The place where you are.
the
word that's also what I know is the
guy there's the after and there is an
relative for example
my what my my children are doing now
according to me is the
an she knows what he's doing and there
is a an which we can know about it with
our using our sound intellect. I'll give
you an example. Gravity the effects of
gravity before gravity. I'll give you
another example. I never seen the person
who made a phone. I never seen the
person who made you with me. I never
seen the person who made a phone. That's
called seen. I haven't seen him. Yes.
But I don't have to see him to know by
you by looking at his product that this
person who made must have a power,
must have a will, must have
intelligence, wisdom, everything. That's
good. Alhamdulillah. So, so this this
type of knowledge you can utilize
yourself in to know about with
certainty. But this type of knowledge
you will never be able or
[Music]
anything the reality of hellfire the
reality of paradise paradise how Allah
his the reality of his attributes his
names his
essence. We don't have a no pro.
Which scientific instrument have we used
to prove all these realities you're
talking about? It's metaphysics.
Unless you study metaphysics before you
can understand this. Metaphysics about
metaphysics. If you study metaphysics,
then you know all this hell and all this
metaphysics. It's not
metaphysics. It's metaphysics.
So you can't say this. I mean even this
term I don't even agree with it.
Okay. They're by evil spirits by Jin.
That's a proof. That's one of the proof.
But the doctor say that's
when they give the medication they do
get better. So it's not the gin. Yeah.
You see mixing. No. No. No. You're
mixing between two things. You think
when we say he's possessed by gin means
that there's no things involved. No.
Doesn't contradict like like sometimes
you have this anxiety. you start beating
but who's the root of the cause of it?
Satan can cause it. You know the gym can
cause it. So So there's no conflict
between for example for example
it talk about gym now I'm not telling
you. Yeah. I'm saying you think that if
the gin possess someone and we can know
that okay the reason that he feel like
is because of this and that negate that
the jin possess him. No I mean when you
treat him with medication he gets
better. He no all the time. All the time
some they go worse. Depends. I saw I saw
them go worse. I could have suicidal
ideation. That's what sometimes it's
inflammation of the mind. Your mind is
inflamed. You know, you have problem
with the the wires. You understand? Some
eat the food that you eat. Sometimes
other things, you know, establish
between the two mental health and
jinism. There's ways to
establish by performing the reading of
Quran. The gin can cause mental health.
Yeah. So, yeah. who man was mental. But
what we say to you after experience
sorry I've experienced the issue of jin
not the Muslims even the Christians
these call knowledge you cannot deny it
but it's not scientific knowledge
prove to me scientifically you talk
about scientifically yeah because I'm
not scientist yeah but that's what I'm
saying big things yeah that's why
science we cannot utilize science for
everything okay cuz here even they say
they say you have a scientific theory
You came to give a new one. Well,
there's there's a scientific test that
proved they used it to prove the evil
eye. And what they said, they got these
guys to look at these numbers on this um
machine. Basically, it does 1 to 100
whatever. And they told them look at
that number and imagine a number and
they effect that the results they will
get were earlier were like random and
they were consistent. But when people
had the sort of thought and looked at
it, it changed the results and there was
nothing else involved in that. So they
they can't explain it but there's an
effect there and this is by scientists
it's not by uh if you go online you can
see this materialist
I think it's possible but scientist
some of them are some of them where you
from the western so you would be lying
oh yeah yeah see no Christian no Muslim
okay so your family no Muslim person
family no Muslims huh because I Muslim
my family
is a you know in the Quran Allah said
you know after I show you prophecies
oh there's a hospital hospital there
don't say that don't bring him here I'm
going to come here
now I'm not a I'm not a Christian
oh don't break him here they hate Allah
they hate Allah don't break him here
they hate Allah
that's why they hate Allah
That's a nice book. It's good to to read
it. Explains that a lot of things. But
what we say the Quran mentioned in you
are clear proof for Allah's existence.
Allah
said Allah said is not the time for the
human being to think and to reflect on
was upon the time worth of mentioning.
Now now you have hearing, you have a
sight, you have everything that cannot
come from blind
matter. You have your side. You didn't
have perfect size. You say you mean?
What do you mean? They say how it
evolved. You didn't have it cannot be
prove it. Can't be prove it. Where did
God put the evolutionary process? No,
no, no. Allah to us clearly Adam is the
first. I mean, of course, Allah says,
but
Allah say God put the Yeah, you're
right. You're right. Even we have some
Muslims here in the park. But in Muslim
countries, they try to say that they
don't win. You know, that's how they're
going to spread Islam. That's screaming.
How do you Islam make a difference? No,
we don't. We don't unite with the false
truth. Islam tell you to unite for the
truth. You don'tite. How do you convince
them to bring? Oh, no. No. You cannot
change people's hearts. They can't
change it. Of course. Well, it's upon
you. Why is upon me to convey the
message? Because prophet
Muhammad is a messenger of Allah. You
get more rewards going to Islam if you
convince. If you convince them they
listen or if they do listen you got to
take the chance to Yeah. Yeah. But some
don't want to listen. They don't some
people like these guys.
They don't do nothing. But
even Christians
that he's doing exactly what the
Christians doing when they go around
Jesus love you. That's how we respect
Christianity. But as a student, they
have nice discussion, respectful
discussion, you know. But what we say
to
you, you have another one. This one is
for
you. That is for you. No, I read it.
I'll read it. No, you have one. It's for
him. It's for him. Respect gift. No, no,
no. He want to give it to No, it's for
him. You have to read, brother. Come
here. Give you one. Next week, we give
you one. I have to read a lot to learn.
No, no. This is a nice one. This
one actually this one. But
let me ask you this honest question.
Which one is more rational and tangible
proof? For this a beautiful universe to
be created with a creator who possess
knowledge and a will and a power and
wisdom always create by a blind matter
always create by non-existent things.
What is the matter?
No
specific cause to happen because there's
like causation. What about blind matter?
Is it possible for
the matter? I know if you're talking
you're going to jump in. It's going to
be a problem. after we
then
he argument that in order for police to
do this to do this he has to call
someone to shoot someone he has to wait
entity no entity of but what I'm saying
in this universe we can see there. I'm
not super knowledgeable to say there's
no God or there's God. I don't have
that. Yeah, but I'm saying I'm not
equipped with all that all the
knowledge. No, you don't have super you
don't have to be super knowledgeable to
come to conclusion of the creation which
we can see there is programmed what is
today Sunday tomorrow Monday. How do you
know that? By sun setting, sun
rising, but there's order. It's
following. Okay. The universe is
following an order. Yes, it's connected.
You have a nose next to your mouth
before you eat smell food. The liquid
that you have in your ears is different
than your eyes. The liquid that you have
in your ears is thicker to prevent
anything going inside. The liquid that
you have in your eyes is thinner to take
things out. You have a teeth in your
mouth that cannot be created by a blind
matter.
What about the penis? Think of that one.
I think the children watch it man. I
show respect because no the do this.
What about penis? What is the word? When
you get married use it. Say that one
also
say
people
watching said we
have it. It's nice.
You can see that's got a job to
do
everything to do. So how do you say
that? stuff. How am I going to learn?
What I'm talking about, you got to be
Muslim to to accept this is a general
knowledge is a common sense.
Is it clear? That's why in the Quran
Allah said from it. No, is it clear?
Allah said they create by nothing or do
they create themselves or they create
the heavens and the earth? Surely they
have no firm belief. Does God say how he
created things? For
example from smoke originally from
Adam to you way to come and then you get
involved. You're breaking the
conversation. And how old is the
universe? What's your name? What's your
name? You older than I know you're old.
Now how old is the universe? Well, I
know you are older than it now. How old
is the universe?
Maybe he's 5 years. No, no, no. How can
the univer listen? Afterwards when you
finish with him, you go from 5 years. 5
years. How can you become
smoke from the
smoke? It doesn't make any sense because
no make is not by necessity
agitating due to our environment
poisoned and affected by the propaganda
and all you understand because me
looking at this universe looking at
oursel which Allah instruct us and
command us and encourage us to do so is
impossible irrational illogical for this
beautiful universe to come without any
powerful uh wise knowledgeable creator
is illogical say just came like that I
don't have to study for university to
have a university to know that knowledge
which is known by necessity that's why
in the Quran speaks about the fra when
the fra has been affected then attacks
or addresses the the sound intellect so
you have to be honest with yourself
before it's too late before it's too
late because you know I find it strange
the mainstream movement
Muslims I find that strange but I don't
know That's their That's the intention.
Why are they doing Islam is the truth?
That's right. Cuz before they should
demonize communists. No. No. From day
one they No. I mean the time the Soviets
and Americans. Yeah. Yeah. But from day
one and now they're demonizing. No. No.
But from day one it's like Muslims are
the new enemy basically. No. From the
media. I find it straight. I just find
it straight. You once you once you look
into it, you will find out who's doing
it. No. From day one. For example, look
in the Quran, Allah mentioned that the
Satan will inspire to change people.
Satan will inspire to will inspire the
creation or the human beings to change
their creation. What we see now with
LGBTQ how Allah, how prophet Muhammad
knew there will come a time when humans
they start changing their own gender.
He's born healthy everything but he
feels a woman or a woman feels like a
man. That is in the Quran. Allah
mentioned it.
How about you know if he was
overwhelming theological guessing say he
just said it no it must be with
intention you keep repeating it saying
the same thing from the side of the
future and it's coming to pass
everything imagine imagine the western
world the wored
Oh, sorry, sorry. Oh, sorry. Sorry.
Yeah. Yeah. One of the West propaganda
against Islam that Islam oppresses
women. Islam oppress women. But the
fastest the majority of rivers in the
western world. When the mainstream media
are propagating this lie are women. So
women that have everything quote unquote
everything they can do whatever they
like. They choose to accept Islam to a
hijab to to live off alcohol
nightclub. Why they why? Because they
understood and they found out that the
true meaning of freedom to become slave
to your creator, not to your society and
Satan and desire. You know, prostitution
is the first to of course.
Yes, of course. Haram is forbidden Islam
to to have prostitution. Why? Because
people sometimes when a woman is poor
have nothing so they do this job instead
and they call the work
I don't know what they call them but I
know it's called
they're trying to justify it's a normal
thing to normalize you know what that's
what what I'm saying is why this British
or French or European American women are
accepting
Islam even though there's a big
propaganda in the western world or other
even
Yeah. No.
Yeah. But you know the propaganda
against Islam if it was under any if it
was against any religion that religion
will be
dead. Islam not just defend it spread in
his world cuz right you know another
prophecy in the Quran Allah mentioned
that Allah will make Islam spread even
if the enemies dislike it.
Again. How we do that?
Muslim is that is that when Jesus comes
according to your belief according to my
belief he wants to be Muslim
come is that when Jesus comes or is it
before that how does it work you know
when Jesus comes back Jesus come back
and he will not accept anything except
Islam from people okay but it'll be too
late this universe belong to Allah the
creator of everything Allah allow his
creation look even if you believe in him
yet Allah is merciful which is
creation but however however Allah you
know you do just believe you are you're
not Muslim you're Catholic of course you
are Catholic you don't believe cavalary
you don't believe you are your fra which
is clearly telling you believe in God
say atheist yeah know atheist Christians
as
well you believe in Islam
so at the moment you shall become Muslim
yes means someone who reject the truth.
So you don't accept the truth. Yes. Did
you get offended when you did you get
offended? Kind of. Yeah. Are you saying
that's something in you, bro? Listen,
take the shahada. No, bro. Islam. I've
never I
disl if I study Islam, I might find
things that I agree with you and then
I'll say okay with me. No, not not
directly Muslim. I may say, "Oh, this
makes sense, but this doesn't make
sense." You have you have to study
Islam. No, I'm trying. Let's say I'm
studying Quran, for example.
Maybe points. Maybe at some point I'm
going to say this doesn't align with my
world view or No, but this part does
make sense. You see what I mean? That's
what I'm trying to say.
At the moment anyone or not at the
moment anyone does not believe in Islam
because Islamic teaching is a K doesn't
mean you're old or you're young you're
fat you're skinny means someone doesn't
Yeah that's it understand so to be
success when you start in the altar be a
Muslim and worship your creator a lot is
not offensive because you need to
worship your creator not offensive you
need to to to to follow Islamic teaching
Is it true? What do you think so far
with the prophecies in the Quran
prophecies? I mean it's overwhelming
somebody.
Which one is not? I can deal with it.
Which one is not? If somebody
happened about Arabs building Arabs.
Yeah. Okay.
to science
of
architecture if it improves over time
then it's possible for me to make higher
structures even in the Egyptian time
they made higher structures
see again let me do this point his point
is prophet Muhammad speaking about the
Arabs in the middle of nowhere okay
no but not everywhere why the not
building why
specify apart from the skysc
No, no, no. But what I'm not saying but
specified but what I'm saying why he
specified the Arabs. Okay. He said 50
years which is more
powerful. No bedwab is more
bedw say bedwinh in the Quran. Say
that what is it? What is in the wrong?
Why did you say
nobody but
anyway we are digressing his way to do
is digress the point here is prophesies
about people they will stop building
tall buildings okay when he said that
there was not any sign or indication
they'll be doing it what he could have
do what he could have done which is more
logical to go in line if he was just
making it up he could have said the
Romans would do it cuz the Romans
already are doing it. But the Arabs will
people of desert. So how do you know the
Arabs will come to power and they start
building tall buildings. So saying the
Arab is more logical rational to say
this prophecy was powerful. Just because
they were in the desert doesn't mean in
the future they going to have more
technology to but it could have exposed
him that they never do it because they
have to say so you taking a risk. You
taking a risk so you taking a risk to to
mention the Arabs. It was more Roger to
mention the Roman and the Persians
because they this question in
the concurrence between people competing
each other. Yes. Even the word even the
word like this
prophet said one of the people is going
to die. He could have said he will come.
Yeah. I would have no wait before
prophetam even the word he used that's
why the word he said they will compete
but he say yeah step by step for that
they will compete with each other they
will compete with each others will
compete with each others compete with
each
other it's not it's not the case
in the lot of petrol a lot of power but
how we know there was nothing when when
this
said now. No, but said it was a pure
desert. 50 years ago Dubai couldn't have
known it. Sorry. Sorry. 50 years ago, if
you went to the Arab Peninsula, you
would never think they will start
building tall buildings. 50 years ago,
let alone 1,400 years ago. Let alone
1,400 years ago. Imagine that. Wasam. So
that's why it's powerful. This one is
powerful as well. As for your question,
you know
Abuaham Allah the Quran and he said Abu
will be in the hellfire. What Abuahab
could have did to expose prophet
Muhammad wasallam and to show Islam is
wrong. He could have just said I'm a
Muslim but he never
did you understand which which
proves and was right.
never except because remember the
enemies of prophet Muhammad wasallam
they were doing everything they were
doing everything to invalidate prophet
they write against him everything so he
he had power he had ability but Allah
sealed him I'm bringing you I'm going
home you going no thank you very much no
but the question antimatter the
antimatter what is antimatter what the
antimatter antimatter antimatter he's
not scientist no no but he mentioned
antimatter no he didn't say anti I said
antimatter no he mentioned antimatter
No, he said matter. He said dark matter.
You said dark matter. No. Did you say
dark matter? I said antimatter. No, he
said matter. Did you say dark matter?
It doesn't matter. It doesn't matter. I
said it doesn't matter again. See you
there.